[Music]
thousands of generations the gunslingers
were Knights just wanna protect us from
the coming of the dark these visions as
you call them what do you see I see a
tower the man in black and the comes
fear future streams they're not real
Jake if you know the world out there
Oh
who are you it's you
you're a gunslinger right there are no
prints latest not anymore
why does the man in black want to
destroy the tower the tower protects
both our worlds if it falls hell will be
unleashed
he's like the devil isn't he no is worse
you can't stop what's coming death
always wins your world might be gone but
mine isn't
you let that telephone Ames of people
die damn guns and bullets in your wall
you're gonna like earth a lot that's
right let's go
you clawing your way out of the darkness
did she tell the kid who ever walked
with you guys by my hand
I will kill him for both of us
you're not aiming my hand
range with his hand has forgotten the
face of his father I aim of my eye
not shoot with my hands I should with my
mind
okay I do not kill with my gun
[Applause]
[Music]
I killed my heart
[Music]